heute sollten hier in den royal court of
justice in london zum allerletzten mal
zeugenaussagen in dem prozess zwischen
johnny depp und der britischen zeitung
the sun
jetzt hat sich dieser ganze prozess kann
aber in die länge gezogen
denn einige zeugenaussagen haben mehr
zeit in anspruch genommen als geplant
das heißt es werden auch nächste woche
noch zeugenaussagen und zwar freundin
von amber heard und damit soll es heute
losgehen denn amber heard selbst saß
gestern zum allerletzten mal im
zeugenstand und hat noch einmal über
ihre beziehung mit johnny depp
gesprochen hat gesagt sie hat ihn über
alles geliebt aber er hat sich in ein
komplettes monster verwandelt als er
alkohol getrunken oder drogen zu sich
genommen hat und über diesen ganzen
prozess habe ich mich jetzt einmal
unterhalten mit einem britischen
reporter von der daily mail der diesen
prozess von anfang an hier begleitet hat
im gerichtsgebäude in einem nebensaal
und da wollen wir jetzt mal rein sehen
ob sie die wurst
johnny depp ist modernen iv in angie
damit das schlimmste das schon wieder
passieren kann ist nicht der finanzielle
schaden sondern die schädigung seines
rufs so sieht er doch selbst deshalb ist
er auch vor gericht gezogen und für die
sun die auch eine sehr einflussreiche
organisation ist und finanziell gut
dasteht geht es um dasselbe die
rufschädigung es geht hier also nicht um
geld um große summen einige anwälte
haben ja geschätzt das ist hier
vielleicht um rund 100.000 geht die
anwaltskosten auf der anderen seite
liegen bei ein bis anderthalb millionen
von für jede seite für die sand für
johnny depp sind das keine hohen beträge
hier geht es also wirklich in den beruf
der ruf einer der größten
boulevardzeitung weltweit gegen den ruf
einer der größten schauspieler der welt
es ist also ein starker kampf 99
wenn man sich diesen prozess wie ein
fußballspiel vorstellt dann sind wir
gerade in der 70 minute und johnny depp
liegt mit 2 1 vorne aber der
schiedsrichter hat noch nicht
abgepfiffen es ist also noch etwas zeit
interessant ist dass die anwälte sowohl
in johnny depps als auch in amber hearn
zeugenaussagen unstimmigkeiten gefunden
haben der tatsachen gesagt die er später
zurücknehmen musste und auch hört es bei
einigen
aussagen irgendwann zurück gerudert aber
wenn man beide aussagen betrachtet würde
ich sagen dass man bisher mehr
unstimmigkeiten in amber heard aussagen
als bei johnny depp gefunden hat